[Applause]
[Music]
ethic and hedge are on the ground floor
of a massive tower barriers of energy
separate them from their quests second
goal the node of creation
[Music]
to reach it
ethic must use three energy streams to
climb the tower as soon as she steps
forward a timer will begin counting down
from 60 seconds at the back of the room
there's a basin made of invisible towers
that can hold energy between them after
one minute a torrent of energy will pour
down from above filling one unit at a
time with a force field preventing it
from spilling out the front or back
during the 60 calm seconds ethic and
hedge must decide exactly how many units
of energy will fall for each of the
three challenges they must choose the
amount that will fill the basin exactly
if they do so the energy will propel
them further upwards but if they get the
amount at all wrong the energy left will
fail dropping them diagrams on the walls
illustrate some examples this
configuration will capture exactly two
units of energy this configuration will
capture four three here and one here and
this one will also capture four because
any energy on the right would spill out
the energy will rain down in such a way
that it will only overflow if there's no
space that could hold it
hedge can make one tower of blocks
visible at a time and count how tall it
is but he can't look at the whole
structure all at once
how does ethic program hedge to figure
out exactly how much energy each basin
can hold pause now to figure it out for
yourself
here's one way of thinking about what's
happening each unoccupied cell will hold
energy if and only if there is a wall
eventually to its left and a wall
eventually to its right but it would
take a long time for hedge to check this
for each individual cell so what if he
were to consider a whole column of
blocks at a time how many units of
energy can this hold for instance let's
analyze the problem by looking at our
example there are five columns of blocks
here the leftmost one can't hold any
energy because there's nothing higher
than it the second stack can have three
units above it as they would be trapped
between these two four block stacks we
get three units by taking the height
where the energy would level off four
and subtracting the height of the stack
so that's 4 minus 1 the third stack is
similar for to the left 4 to the right
and it's 3 high so it'll hold 4 minus 3
equals one unit the fourth stack and
fifth stacks have nothing higher than
them to the right so they can't hold any
energy we can adapt this idea into an
algorithm considering one column at a
time as the point of reference hedge can
look to the left stacked by stack to
find the height of the tallest one look
to the right to find the height of the
tallest one and take the smaller of the
two as the height the energy can fill up
two if the result is higher than the
column in question subtract the height
of the original column and the result
will be the number of units that column
can hold
if it's equal to or below the level of
the column in question the energy would
spill off hedge can apply that to an
entire Basin with a loop that starts on
the leftmost column and moves right one
column at a time for each column he'll
run the same steps look all the way left
for the tallest do the same to the right
take the lower height of the two
subtract the original column height and
increase the grand total if that number
is positive
his loop will repeat as many times as
there are columns that will work but
it'll take a long time for a large basin
at every step hedge repeats the action
of looking left and looking right if
there are n stacks he'll look at all n
stacks and times is there a faster way
here's one time-saver before doing
anything else
hedge can start on the left and keep a
running tally of what the highest stack
is here that would be 2 2 again since
the first was higher than 4 for 4 he can
then find the highest right most stacks
by doing the same going right to left 1
3 4 4 4 in the end he'll have a table
like this in his memory now hedge can
take one more pass to calculate how much
energy there will be above every stack
with the same equation from before take
the smaller of the stored left and right
values and subtract the height of the
current tower instead of looking at n
stacks and times he'll look at n stacks
just three times which is what's called
linear time there are ways to optimize
the solution even further but this is
good enough for our hero's ethic and
hedge work as one
the first cascade is a breeze and they
rise up the tower the second is a little
tougher
the third is huge with dozens of stacks
of blocks the timer ticks down towards
zero but ethics program is fast she gets
the wheel in position just in time and
the energy lifts them to the node of
creation
like the first it reveals a vision
memories of years gone by the world
machine changed everything and ethic in
her position as chief robotics engineer
grew troubled by what she saw when the
Bradbury er went up to keep the people
in she knew something was seriously
wrong so she created three artifacts
with the ability to restore people's
power creativity and memory and smuggled
them to three communities before she
could tell people how to use them the
government discovered her efforts and
sent bots to arrest her and the other
programmers the last thing used the
world machine to create was a robot that
would protect the ancient device from
the forces of ignorance by enclosing it
in a giant maze she named her creation
hedge without warning the energy lived
flickers and then fizzles out continue
the adventure in Episode eight of think
like a coder or restart the journey with
episode 1 and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]